desde la llegada hoy a bagdad del papá
francisco dejó claro que este será un
viaje cargado de simbolismos de webber
después de haber pasado en la parte
oficial la reunión con el primer
ministro y luego con el presidente que
lo recibió con todos los honores en su
palacio presidencial asistió al primer
encuentro con la comunidad cristiana
estaban ahí todas las figuras de la
iglesia en irak presentes en esa
catedral de nuestra señora de la
salvación que fue uno de los lugares que
ha vivido uno de esos momentos más
tristes de los cristianos en la última
década con un ataque de al qaeda que
dejó más de 50 muertos en aquel momento
allí se sentó el papá francisco donde
había muerto esa gente mandando un
mensaje a los terroristas de que este
país no se va a dejar vencer por
sus actos ni tampoco ni las minorías
pero también mandó un mensaje para la
convivencia de todos en iraní dijo que
ese era el propósito uno de los
propósitos de esta visita mañana viajará
a la ciudad de nayaf donde se encontrará
con el ayatolá alí sistaní la figura
religiosa más importante de este país en
otro acto cargado de simbolismo y
viajará al sur a nazi villa al lugar
donde estará el origen del profeta
abraham y que es uno de los lugares en
donde confluyen todas las religiones